let's check in with Lisa D'Angelo you
guys were down 11. 11 and went on a
key to the turnaround defense defense um
as a group he wasn't shooting the ball
well it wasn't getting to getting out in
transition getting the easy ones we
locked up defensively and got easy ones
as a group you may not have been
shooting well but you have 21 points
five threes in that first half just
what's been working for you you just
locked in the weather's nice
all right thank you thank you
the weather's beautiful but right now
everybody
in Laker land feeling good after that
rough stretch in the first quarter the
Lakers bounced back in a big way
halftime game three series all tied at
one a piece
and the Lakers have an 11 point lead
foreign